[Applause]
welcome to your weekly ticket
work-from-home edition and let me -
honey okay alright first up it looks
like another film has had its theatrical
release delayed this time it's Warner
Brothers film Wonder Woman 1984 the
movie's theatrical release has moved
from June 5th to August 14th later this
year this is of course because of the
growing concerns around the corona virus
which has delayed several films
including Disney's Mulan and universals
no time to die Wonder Woman's director
patty Jenkins made the announcement via
Twitter saying we made Wonder Woman 1984
for the big screen and I believe in the
power of cinema and these terrible times
when theater owners are struggling as so
many are we are excited to read eight
hour film to August 14 2020 and a
theater near you and pray for better
times for all bye then
I'll read eight that's a way better way
of saying it now this isn't the first
film that WB has postponed theatrically
lin-manuel Miranda's in the heights has
also been postponed but still doesn't
have a release date there's no word on
Christopher Nolan's Tennant which is
still on their slate to be released in
theaters July 17th but we'll keep you up
to date that's why you gotta watch this
show okay here's some good news
Universal Pictures has decided to
release trolls world tour or trolls to
digitally the same day it's being
released theatrically on April 10th
it'll be available to rent for a premium
rental price on that date and hey if you
need to catch up on trolls it's always
available on Fandango now
but maybe you're stuck inside like us
and you're trying to figure out what you
want to watch on digital well that's why
we're here and I thought I'd bring on
managing editor at mandingo Erik Davis
to give us some personal recommendations
Erik what he got for us today
all right well kale I miss sports big
time I missed my basketball baseball
season supposed to start right about now
I miss hockey I miss all of it and so I
just watched the way back which is a new
film with Ben Affleck maybe my favorite
Ben Affleck performance in a while maybe
since Batman and he plays a coach who's
trying to get this down on their luck
basketball team turned around and while
he gets his life turned around from
being an alcoholic battling some demons
there it's a great underdog sports story
so if you are a fan of the underdog
sports movies and you are someone like
me who is really missing sports right
now give the wayback a chance what about
Carol what about you when you watching
man for me it's got to be Sonic the
Hedgehog
I've been waiting for this to come
digital digital for a while I was
pleasantly surprised by how much I
actually enjoyed the movie I didn't know
what to expect
basically Sonic is lost in in our world
and has to try and find friends but he
ends up finding also enemies at Jim
Carrey kills it as dr. Robotnik it's
it's just a good time and you need a
good time right now it's it it's for the
whole family
mom and dad will enjoy it the kids will
enjoy it fans of Sonic the Hedgehog will
enjoy it that's my personal
recommendation I love it I can't wait to
watch it again after we film this so
thank you very much Eric stay safe peg
so much kal stay safe yourself
also available on Fandango now are the
two highest-grossing films of the year
bad boys for life and Sonic the Hedgehog
hey I remember someone mentioning that
one it was me
I mentioned bad boys for life also
received an early digital release and is
available to watch on Fandango now Will
Smith and Martin Lawrence's old-school
cops team up with a younger crew of
high-tech police officers including
Vanessa Hudgens Alexander Ludwig and
Charles mountain setting the stage for
lots of generational jokes this third
installment is full of the classic
trademark quips and self-aware jokes
like the first two bad boy movies but
with tons more action Ben Schwartz who
voices Sonic the Hedgehog in the new
movie tweeted the news saying gotta go
digital fast this fun family-friendly
film includes performances by Jim Carrey
James Marsden tika Sumpter and of course
Ben Schwartz and Sonic is not the only
animated movie being released on digital
earlier than expected
Disney Pixar has also released their
latest movie onward onto digital despite
the movie only coming to theaters a few
weeks prior alright well that's it thank
you for joining me in my home leave me a
comment letting me know what you'll be
watching or if there's anything people
should be catching up on alright see you
next week
[Music]
you
[Music]